we all know that trust is important but
what what is it really
um so i'll give you an example it's sort
of one of my favorite examples of what a
trusting team looks like
um so i a bunch of years ago i was in
vegas for a
business trip and they were very nice to
put me up down the street at the four
seasons
beautiful hotel the four seasons over
here happens to have a coffee bar in the
lobby
and so one afternoon i went and bought
myself a cup of coffee
and the the barista working that day
named noah
he was charming and funny and engaging
and i stood there for far too long
talking to noah
and as is my nature i asked noah
do you like your job
without skipping a beat noah said i love
my job
now in my line of work that's
significant
like is rational right i like the people
i like the work i get paid well i like
my job love is emotional it's a higher
order connection like do you love your
wife i like her a lot right
it's it's different right
and noah said i love my job so for me i
was like oh that's a hierarchy
connection this kid's emotionally
connected to his job so immediately i
followed up and said can you tell me
specifically what the four seasons is
doing that you would even say to me i
love my job
and again he didn't skip a beat he said
yeah throughout the day managers will
walk past me and ask me how i'm doing
ask me if there's anything that i need
to do my job better not just my manager
any manager
and then he said i also work at another
hotel
he says and there the managers catch us
when we're doing things wrong he says
they're the managers put pressure on us
simply to make our numbers and perform
there i like to keep my head below the
radar and just get through the day and
collect my paycheck only at the four
seasons he said do i feel there's that
word again do i feel i can be myself
what i find so profound about that story
is this is the exact same human being in
two different companies in two different
leadership environments and our
experience of him will be profoundly
different not because of the person but
because of the place he works
right it's not the person very often
and so uh you know when we talk about oh
you can't get good people these days i'm
like hmm
you know it's like the only common
factor in all my failed relationships is
right
it's like if if there's no good people
ever that you can hire i'm thinking hmm
there's one common factor and all those
people who are leaving you
that might be you um
and and and
uh uh
and and noah's experiences you know we
have these we have this twisted
thoughts about how we get the most out
of our people like how am i going to get
the most out of a mate people are not a
towel that you ring them out how much
you can get out of them you know the
question is what kind of environment can
i create in which my people can work at
their natural best